yeah whenever I always felt like it
would be really cool going on a talk
show because you get your own intro
music and then John was telling I don't
know how the hell we came up with this
song I like wonder what my intro music
repeat but anyway so my name is Jack as
Sam was saying like today I advise a few
different startups but previously I
found a startup called bungle and last
year I came down and I gave this talk
about how I pulled off an insane
marketing stunt using LinkedIn
advertising to get the last spot at an
incubator called angel pad a bit kind of
like Y Combinator
and that talks online if you want to
check it out that it was quite a popular
talk but Sam asked me to come down and
basically talk about what happened after
you got into the accelerator they gave
us like a hundred thousand dollars but
what happened afterwards and I want to
also give you guys some tips like what
worked for me some tips
going into seed funding raising your
kind of first round of funding
I know during the Q&A for some of the
other speakers some people had um
questions on that light approaching
angel masters and stuff so I want to
give you some tips so to kind of pick up
where the story left off basically it
was a Thursday and Angel Pat told us all
right guys you've got the last spot in
our incubator and it starts on Monday so
just get the first flight out to America
we were in London at the time and you
start on Monday and so me and my
business partner two of us got on a
plane and Angel pad is basically like I
said bit like Y Combinator school for
startups you have about 12 companies in
each batch and what they make you do is
you basically arrive we actually had our
suitcases we're like turning up at the
with our suitcases and the first thing
you have to do is pitch your company to
all of your other teams sitting down
so we're basically sitting there
listening to eleven other companies and
we're quickly realizing like right all
of these other companies the founders
are like the most like totally legit
engineers like one team like they have
PhDs in video encoding and worked at
Google one guy had written YouTube's API
and we were kind of the joke of the
class basically me my biz apana we're
not engineers so people were like all
right guys you've got a terrible idea
here that the ideas changed now but we
have a terrible idea and you've got no
one touch it build it like you guys just
gonna flop so bad actually remember my
business partner early on in the program
one other team was getting a bit more
investor interest you know a bit ahead
of other companies they were kind of
feeling bullish getting investor
interest and one of the founders
actually came out to my business partner
and he said hey I'll lead your
fundraising round here's a quarter
you're gonna need it and I think the
part was I so pissed off my hand like
they're just like going psyched up and
and so I just want to tell the story
today like all right how did we go from
like being the joke of the class to we
raised the most money for the seed round
at that class RC van was two million
dollars led by Google Ventures and then
how did we become kind of break out this
race there's 25 million total and the
most employees how did we go from being
the joke to the breakout especially on a
fundraising side and I want to give you
some tips about stuff that we maybe
didn't know these tips but this has went
well for us and noticed it didn't go as
well for some of the other teams so to
start off so one day if the school for
startups our office one day one of the
founders from the other teams turns up
in like a pinstripe suit looking like
Gordon Gekko and we're like dude what
you doing like you know you're an
engineer you're normally dressing in
like hoodies and startup t-shirts like
why you coming in a pinstripe suit what
was the deal and he basically said last
like he was talk to up guys like I you
just see like who's an investor gonna
invest in he's going west in like me
like looking presentable and investable
was he gonna investing you guys like in
hoodies and start up t-shirts etc the
thing is what he didn't understand is
that especially where he's a sieve and
it's not it's not it's not a present a
it's not a show that you put me on it's
not like hey let me just dress up like
his in a hoodie all the time it's not
like hey let me just put my pinstripe
suit I go to a VC boardroom
I like stand up and I do my pitch and
then I'm like hey G do you want to give
me money it doesn't work like that
they're investing in you as a person and
what you're doing and so basically what
he was doing and what a lot of people
raising money for the first time do it's
basically it can be quite daunting it's
like hey this these BC exbc they're
managing like a billion dollars under
management and I've just got my tiny
startup we're just getting off the
ground like obviously they have all the
control like what can I offer them zone
so startup space of going in basically
they do their pitch and then like hey so
what you think judge or to you on invest
and you're basically just like begging
for money you know that doesn't make you
appealing to invest him and so the first
tip that I've got is kind of to just
change the dynamic of control that
you've got in your head how you're
thinking about approaching a fund
raising don't be putting yourself down
and putting them on this like another
level like they're like gods you know
what happens with Vangel and this is you
can't really manufacture this because
VCS they're gonna be meeting hundreds of
entrepreneurs a year right so you can't
really manufacture this but to give you
an example the complete flipper opposite
of the last slide when we were raising
seed round for fungal initially we only
wanted we didn't think we could raise
any money so we started out thinking hey
let's try and raise $500,000 and what
happened is once we
got to $500,000 then the meetings
changed because you're going in to meet
a VC and you're talking like hey this is
what we do blah blah and I okay cool how
much money are you raising and we're
like we're raising half a million does
and okay cool so how much have how much
have you raised how much the round is
left and we're like well we've actually
already got half a million and so
they're like okay well why are you
meeting us and we were ten the two
flight based at the time move like well
look we've heard really good things
about you and for the right partner then
maybe we'd like consider raise a bit
more money and so here what you get is
the VC is basically having to pitch the
VP's were basically pitching us like
this is why you should consider raising
more and to let us invest so if you
think of the dynamic the decision-making
dynamic from the previous one an
entrepreneur might go in and like this
why do do you wanna invest and VC is
making a decision here they were
pitching us like would you consider
raising more to make space for us and so
we're having a decision to make so those
the flip opposites is hard to
manufacture this but you can at least do
more of a level playing field and so the
level playing field is thinking all
right I'm not going in begging for cash
and destiny on a billion dollars no
matter who it is a VC's job is to be
finding core startups they're paranoid
all the time as well like Jason
Calacanis spoke earlier that guy that
missed out on uber and how his nights
still upset with herself his job is to
find cool startups like you and sure you
he's got money he or she has got money
and you want that but it's a level
playing field and so you should be
having a conversation and that leads me
into my next hip which is basically that
for your pitch deck you have a family's
in pitch leg some of the best meetings
we had we never even got the deck out we
just had a conversation actually our
series
a VC invested in our seed round and then
led the series I when we met them we
actually met him in his in his living
room he was just like in his slippers
and he's like four year old daughters
like running around but that was a great
environment because where it's you know
he's not in a boardroom where you're
like coming in during presentation we're
in just an informal setting so going for
coffee meetings and stuff like that kind
of great and so if you make your pitch
deck like a picture book so this is one
of the slides from our seed round deck
you see it's like big pictures not much
text at all like maximum like one
sentence like this is like two-year-olds
book like a two-year-old picture book
would look like this right but the thing
is if you make your debt like this even
if you don't debt they get the deck out
when you're just having that
conversation with a VC you can be
thinking in your head you can be
thinking what your slide deck looks like
in your head you could be like okay
because it's like a picture book
it's like chapters right so you're like
right first I'm gonna talk about the
team then I'm gonna talk about the
market size then I'm gonna talk about
like our traction so you can be having
the deck you've struck so it feels like
a natural conversation but you've got
structure to the conversation because
you're thinking about your deck in your
head some pitch decks are startups they
try and cram all their information onto
the slides you have like cash flow
forecasts and like decision making and
like so much text one no ones that
you're going to read that and two they
shouldn't be reading your slides they
should just this should just be giving
structure to a natural conversation
that's where it works best where you can
build a relationship now the tip here
will be to make your traction whatever
your traction is if when different
people make it memorable one one set up
I met recently like this is just made up
but their traction slide actually have
more stuff than this it's like hey we've
got like two thousand downloads and like
two hundred of those I like active users
and the three hundred of them are like
monthly and then temp same conversion
way and
what the hell and an investor's like not
gonna remember that coming out it's like
hey the startups are amazing like okay
how how they doing amazing
I don't know they had like loads of
stats what we did with bungle win like
what you could do is have like one
headline figure whatever your headline
figure is downloads users money revenue
and a time frame can also that makes
your growth kind of seem more explosive
like if you're like hey we just launched
three weeks ago and we've got 2,000
users then that's like okay call this
growing pretty fast if you didn't have
the time frame that could be like okay
you've got 2,000 users like did you
launch two years ago like you know this
gives it a bit of framing and it's also
more memorable so when you go out that
VC can be telling there are partners
yeah this company's killing it like they
just got like two thousand downloads in
the last week so think about the story
of whatever your traction metrically
chooses last last tip is um be able to
describe what your business does in the
frame of a tweet because you've got to
think like as I said they're coming out
the meeting and if I'm psyched about
company I'm advising the good ones and
I'm telling my friend about it I've got
to pitch your startup when I'm pitching
when I when you leave the meeting you're
not there anymore
so how am I gonna describe you if you've
used so much jargon and crazy stuff that
only you can understand what you're
doing there's not gonna work you know
so Sequoia one of the top VC's one of
the partners they had a story that he
met this team of amazing engineers but
they were using so much jargon and like
so complicated they described my doing
and he's like look I don't actually
understand what you do here's a deal
here's a business card right on the back
what you do I'm gonna go outside for
like five minutes when I come back
describe your business you can only use
the words you've written on this
business card because he wanted it to be
hey just make a simple description what
you do right so he left the room he came
back and
the engineer and I said like it great
engineer he had he'd used kind of like
short Co he'd used like a code to cram
loads of words in so he had like a
symbol that actually meant like a
sentence and so they didn't end up
getting investment from Sequoia one bit
that can help with this an exercise
could be if you ask your friends maybe
that don't work with you but maybe if
you've got roommates partner girlfriend
boyfriend
whoever around you ask them if you were
gonna tell someone else about my
business or if you work at you we're
gonna pitch my business how would you
describe it and you can listen to the
words that they use and if they describe
something totally which your business
doesn't do that then you really think
you should realize like okay we need to
rethink how we're talking about what we
do you know
so hopefully that gave you some that was
a quick bit just giving some different
tips for if you're raising money for the
first time or raising seed funding and
hopes of their help this my email
address happy to if anyone wants to
reach out or if there's any questions
anyone have now thanks a lot guys
hey Jack my name's John I love your
tactic on LinkedIn and have a good
investment congratulations
what's your plan for fungal and where
are you taking it so I'm not working at
fungal anymore and the two of us arrived
me and my co-founder and my co-founders
kind of leading it and two of us arrived
off the plane and now there's like a
hundred and eighty of the team I'm
Vangel what it does it basically does
like video advertisements within mobile
apps and games Vangel really we were
just like at the perfect timing because
when we launched mobile apps just use
like banner ads and stuff and so video
was very disruptive today there keep on
growing and actually different markets
internationally has started to get quite
big so bungles got an office in China
now and that generates quite a bit of
revenue it's kind of when you have a
model that works one of the next bits
can be let's try and take this
internationally and that's fungals Bay
at the moment yes so there's a number of
companies in the same space dongle
and it's the same with lots of
businesses bonus when we started bungle
there wasn't really anyone else just
doing video advertisements unity they
kind of build a development platform and
then let you put ads into that as part
of it and bungle is set for it so not
all games are built in unity games might
be built in other stuff I'm not the best
to kind of pitch the differences but
what I know is that app developers like
having different choices they don't just
one have one company you know they want
to have different choices and so Vangel
definitely from the stories I've heard
of app developers feels kind of a need
for a lot of people it sounded like most
of the talk was talking about what you
did after that 500k yeah can you talk a
bit about that first 500k and how you
got to it sure yeah that's definitely a
good point and it's important always to
yeah I like to go into the depths are so
basically a lot of the initial investors
we got we went to this angel pad
incubator and we met a number of people
through this incubator I can say we were
raising I don't got bit limited time but
basically a number of the first people
we met during the the incubator at the
demo day we met some different people
and the first bit for us was getting the
first raising half-million the first bit
was getting 250 K okay once we got 250 K
anyone you go meet you saying raising
half a million we've already got half of
it there's been more control the first
part we built a relationship Google
Ventures was the first one we'd be able
to relationship with them through the
program so they source at the start and
it's all like okay you guys are terrible
and in this to us at the end and they're
like okay we've made a lot of progress
and we also were framing it like hey
thanks so everyone that we met we're
like taking on their advice and we're
like this is how we implemented it we
also got some offers one of our very
first angel investor had founded a
company in the space the know bose found
also talked about this you know like has
someone else started a company in space
or investment company in space
I just called emailed the founder of
another company and mobile our company
it sold his company I was like hey looks
like you're kind of legit in the space
and so to start up I'd love to get your
thoughts on what we're doing we went and
met him showed him what we're doing and
he's like hey I'm like by the way I
actually like do some angel investing
I'd love to invest that's how we got the
very first capital and that gave us way
more credibility as well like hey this
guy who's had an exit he's backing
another mobile ad company cool thank you
okay all right thanks a lot guys
okay this is our last speaker